Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my full Marvel what if episode 8 video
RIP the multiverse.
Because Ultron has all six infinity stones.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
to a bunch of things.
I'll also explain what's going on with the
watcher because he is crazy powerful.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos in working
to get Hawkeye episodes after what if they'll
be like the next big Marvel Disney plus series
and I will be doing videos for that to but
careful for spoilers from the episode.
If you have not seen it yet.
Just turning the beginning of work our way
through moments and Easter eggs we go along.
Starting with the title of the episode what
if Ultron one.
So not only was the episode.
Based on an alternate version of Avengers:
Age of Ultron the Marvel movie, but it was
also based on the age of Ultron comic book
storyline.
And I would argue is actually more accurate
to the comic book than the movie was but one
of the big differences in the way they open
the episode was the watcher actually starts
out being super bummed out way more than usual.
He laments tragic endings like oh this is
sad and then moves on to the next universe
in the next episode or the next comic book
story for talk about the what if comics, but
this time in the episode.
He literally says the phrase this one breaks
my heart Ultron in the episode was voiced
by Rossmoor can who was the voice of red skull
and Avengers endgame in Avengers infinity war
I didn't know was he until actually check
the credits Jeremy Renner was back is Hawkeye
in all the other people or played by the same
People who been playing them throughout the whole series
Like some of the Marvel movie actors came
back.
Like Benedict Cumberbatch was playing Doctor
Strange supreme at the end of the episode
with the actual plot picks up.
Just at the end of the events of Avengers:
Age of Ultron in the universe where Ultron
beat the avengers again all six infinity stones.
So the night and Segovia when this is happening
this is meant to be a post apocalyptic Moscow,
Russia it even though it's snowing here in
this is happening is kind of meant to be a
nuclear winter, because Ultron hacked all
the nuclear warheads of every nation and fire
them using then to destroy humans instead
of using this to cobia plot with the giant
vibranium missile is a very black widow Hawkeye
heavy episode.
We start with this version of black widow
being chased down by Ultron's robots and she's
working with Hawkeye Jeremy Renner like as
I came back to play the character you notice
he has a metal arm assuming that he lost it
at some point earlier in their fight against
Ultron after all the nukes went off is that
the ronin haircut but not the full ronin costume,
he also has a legit cloak of invisibility
now it's not Doctor Strange is magic like
one of those kinds of clothes.
It just advanced technology then as he's done
in all the episodes the watcher manifests
above them watching in search narrating the
history of this universe and what led up to
the big nexus event.
And what wound up changing everything.
Starting with Iron Man accidentally creating
Ultron using the mind stone.
Just like he did during Avengers Age of Ultron
the big nexus event in this reality was the
avengers in this universe never stole vision's
body from Ultron before he could finish uploading
his consciousness to it.
So after he finishes putting himself in the
new vibranium body he use the power of the
mind stone is extra upgraded tech powers to
annihilate the planet.
This is where we get to the age of Ultron
comic book plot that's basically what happened
in age of Ultron Ultron winds up taking over
the whole planet all the vision stuff that
was part of that that was just from the movie
in the comics, instead of vibranium, he winds
up using adamantium to upgrade his body.
Maybe during Marvel phase 5, that's will start
hearing the adamantium inside the MCU.
Then this whole scene here is just meant to
be Tony Stark's vision from the beginning
of Avengers Age of Ultron division that he
was given by scarlet witch of all the avengers deaths
Now obviously they kind of pay that off in
the MCU movies during avengers infinity war,
when he winds up killing most of the avengers.
This version is just meant to be another version
of that reference the camera pans over all
their dead bodies Captain America Thor, even
the Hulk.
He saved Iron Man for last is a brief cameo
scene from thunderbolt Ross to seems like
he's in the Pentagon while they watch all
the nukes go off all over the world it explaining
that Hawkeye black widow survive because they
were at high altitude when all the nukes went
off Hawkeye mentions his wife Laura Barton
his children would've also been killed to
I know everybody's wondering where his wife
is during the Hawkeye trailer.
Don't worry we'll talk about that when we
get the next big Hawkeye trailer live action
MCU Laura Barton hasn't gone anywhere yet,
then the watcher literally mentions age of
Ultron another reference to the movie and
to the classic comic book story were Ultron
does wind of conquering the world.
And then we find out the crazy way, he winds
up getting all six infinity stones.
So apparently in this universe.
Either there was a time jump during that montage
we just saw for this version of thanos just
winds of coming to earth to seal the mind
stone little bit sooner this is meant to be
a reference to avengers infinity war with
the scene of him showing up to kill vision
ripping the mind stone out of his for it.
Only in this reality, the second he steps
out of the space stone portal Ultron notices
and analyze the infinity gauntlet and slices
in half and conveniently thanos already had
all the other five infinity stones.
So we were all wondering how Ultron got the
soul stone after episode seven ending turns
out he did need to do anything.
No sacrifice needed.
And I think this is actually accurate to the
way they explained in the MCU movies.
Because the whole thing about sacrificing
the soul for soul seems like it was only meant
to apply to vormir like only one person needs
to do that than anybody after that can use
the soul stone without sacrificing another
soul for it.
But he weilds all six infinity stones embedding
them in his chest, so he doesn't need the gauntlet
like a regular organic life form his body
is just strong enough because is made of vibranium
and when he becomes a living infinity gauntlet
he gains cosmic awareness on par with the
watcher's was like he's watching the entire
universe all at the same time he is the reality
stone to raise his army back up in then create
a spaceship to collect them just to basically
carry them together and portal them around
the universe as he conquers everything.
Starting with Asgard where he goes full Ragnarok
in this scene is literally meant to parallel
the destruction of Asgard when surtur destroyed
it in Thor Ragnarok is phrase peace in our
time is also an Iron Man quote next is the
sovereign race from guardians of the galaxy
two inconveniently Emmy bending over backwards
the guardians just happened to be here when
he attacks they wanted to feature a lot of
the other Marvel characters in groups as he
went around the universe.
So I think they just kind of combined a lot
of these seems like okay will just a the guardians
just happened to be here.
The same time for those of you asking though
how come Adam warlike didn't help out here
because he would be super powerful not quite
as powerful as Ultron with all six infinity
stones, but still enough to hold him back
a little bit longer the ideas they probably
weren't allowed to use Adam warlike in this
episode because James Gunn is saving him for
guardians of the galaxy 3.
Like the neck and let them debut a huge character
like that on the TV show when they're saving
it for a movie any visit, Sakaar, so RIP Korg
and the grandmaster Valkyrie was also probably still here
This time in then he goes to ego the living
planet, who is the celestial with crazy cosmic powers
So he should been able to put up a bigger
fight against Ultron's army the infinity gauntlet
would be too powerful for a go to stop, but
still to that the episode was so short and
had to speedrun this because it would've been
really cool to see the other celestials versus
Ultron to then he goes to Xandar kills the
nova corps destroys that planet.
And because he's increase crawlspace Captain
Marvel shows up to fight him.
But even though her big thing is soaking energy
damage.
She is in powerful enough to soak all of the
energy damage from the infinity gauntlet.
Of course, because all or references are stuck
in the 80s and 90s.
She makes a Terminator reference, calling
Ultron Skynet and talking about killer robot movies
But apparently she never saw Terminator two
because she quips that the killer robot movie
does not need a sequel.
As if she doesn't know the terminator to exist
as you probably guess the reason why she doesn't
know the terminator to exist is because she
left planet Earth in 1989.
And she was in outer space.
She didn't come back to earth and learn about
what happened till 1995, so she was basically
skipped over in miss Terminator two the captain
Marvel versus Ultron fight is pretty sure
they do give her a bit of a fight scene she
punches him down the planets core, but he
still too powerful because he has all six
infinity stones and winds up giving off an energy burst
so big that it destroys all the planets in
the system.
So RIP Captain Marvel in this isn't even the
biggest kill that he makes he literally winds
up eating the galaxy later in the episode.
So take that Galactus don't worry, I'll talk
about that to that was a very galactus level
boss move, but then he is this long dark night
of the soul kind of moment where he realizes
that he no longer has a purpose.
Because he has brought peace to the universe.
You think his brain would extrapolate the
existence of the multiverse before the big watcher twist
But obviously they wanted to have that big
watcher versus Ultron scenes.
That's why they did the way they did in the
episode in the way Ultron learns about the
watcher in the existence of the multiverse
is very similar to the way the doctor Strange
supreme learned about the existence of the
watcher.
Like he became so powerful in his episode
that he sensed the watcher watching him.
Like who are you.
Who's out there.
So in that same way as the watcher is narrating
events Ultron kind of turns around like a
wait a minute, who's who's talking to me what's
going on in sets off to find a way into the
watchers extradimensional stronghold.
So in the comics, the watcher literally has
a secret based on the moon where he watches
everything from on the what if series.
This MCU version of who want to is basically
inside what you consider an extra dimensional
space is kind like a nexus space that's connected
to every universe of the multiverse.
Like all the panes of glass here show him
different universes that he peeps so later
when Ultron burst through and they start punching
each other through different universes it's
meant to pay off the intro scene where they
show the swirling panes all breaking different
realities all swirling in the background.
But as he narrates later the last hope for
the multiverse is actually Arnim Zola if you
could believe it, which seems like a crazy
twist.
But I guess it makes sense per the logic of
the episode, because in this reality vision
was never created otherwise they would just
use vision for this.
So Hawkeye and black widow go to the KGB archives
in Russia Hawkeye makes a Raiders the lost
Ark reference to the big US government secret
warehouse from the movie black widow pulls
out red guardian shield.
It has the red Star rush on it meant to be
a mere for Captain America shield with the
American star on because red guardian was
Russia's version of Captain America.
Which he reference every chance that he got
during the black widow movie the watcher almost
breaking his oath to help Clint find Arnim
Zola file is meant to foreshadow him putting
the multiverse avengers team together with
dark Doctor Strange at the end of the episode.
Like okay fine you when I see now, please
help me save the multiverse Hawkeye makes
a star wars reference the death Star plans
are not in the main computer.
That's right out of the beginning of a new
hope dark class are not in this reality.
The way they explain this alternate version
of Arnim Zola he went of uploading himself
to the computer at Camp Lehigh like we saw
during the winter soldier movie.
But there was also a copy of his consciousness
backed up inside the hydra winter soldier
base in Siberia black widows of the camp Lehigh
computers were already destroyed per the events
of Captain America winter soldier because
that happened before age of Ultron.
While they're busy traveling there Ultron
finally figures out how to break into the
watchers extradimensional space in they fight
it out before he manages to kick them out
briefly then this will make a lot of you agents
of shield fans happy because when they boot
Arnim Zola up the first thing he says is making
an agents of shield reference hello agents
of shield we learn Hawkeye's middle name is
Francis after his Me-maw it's a family name
maybe though joke about that during the Hawkeye
series black widow trolls Ultron by dialing
the avengers tower in even though Ultron is
not inside this universe as they explain later
in the episode.
It's Ultron's hive consciousness.
This answering it, so technically it is Ultron
who answering the phone at the avengers tower
in apparently it is pizza time in this Hydra
base pizza time they use one of Hawkeye's
trick arrows to upload Arnim Zola into the
Ultron bought but because it's a hive mind
and they need to be in the same dimension
are the same reality as Ultron in he's in
the watchers extradimensional space this obviously
a twist.
They're saving for the finale when Arnim Zola
references other genocidal maniacs that he's
had to contend with.
He's referencing both Hitler and red school
because of World War II then Hawkeye sacrificing
himself to take out the robots is meant to
be a twist on avengers endgame when it was
black widow sacrificing herself then setting
up more the multiverse avengers crossover.
They kind of explain the twist about how they
have to travel into the same universe as Ultron.
Even though we don't see them do that, during
this episode.
Obviously, because the watchers going to dark
Doctor Strange they're going to go around
to different realities, collecting all the
heroes from the multiverse.
All the big main characters from each of the
different episodes.
But then we get our big watcher versus Ultron
fight is basically the entire last third of
the episode.
A lot of you also notice the way they animate
of the watchers power so it.
When he's using his cosmic energy they actually
animate using the Kirby Krackle.
The Kirby Krackle is what that bubbling energy
is is the way that Jack Kirby would animate
cosmic energy they also use that during Spider-Man
into the spider verse.
It is meant to represent cosmic power it as
you can see the watcher is super OP like he
can withstand and soak a lot of damage from
the full infinity gauntlet they start punching
each other through a bunch of different universes
as if there shattering through glass windows
just like the intro scene.
Notice the watchers energy shield that he
uses here is not magic that he's using his
cosmic power just a little bit different.
But the same basic affect is Doctor Strange
is shields age as the watcher is way more
powerful than Doctor Strange then when he
manifests his full armor that's right out
of the comics, all the watchers dress similarly,
but they all have slightly different variations
in their armor and the clothes they wear one
small detail or maybe not so small detail
that I love about their fight here too is
when the watcher uses his giant head to head.
But Ultron like of course she would use her
giant head.
It was super strong that I won't name every
single reality that they travel to here just
a really crazy ones.
But each of these different realities that
they travel to our different versions of earth.
Because that's where the watcher was watching
when they were fighting each other in the
area is meant to be around the New York City
area, they travel to an earth where this in
advance Egyptian culture this taken over the
planet, then the next one.
The earth is covered in volcanoes and flowing
lava then another one stuck in an Ice Age
and then there's another one where they created
the Dyson sphere it looks exactly like the
ones the dwarves of Nidavelir used to harness
the power of the sun for more efficient energy.
I'm not totally sure which one.
This is meant to be though with all the floating
obelisks then we get our big Ultron galactus
level boss move so he makes himself go super
size kind of like Galactus but actually I
would take it one step further and say that
he's way more powerful than galactus in this
scene here because galactus only towers over
planets like individual planets not galaxies
any can only siphon energy from one planet
of the time.
This is the entire Milky Way galaxy that Ultron
destroys in this universe with a single crunch
then he punches him into a reality were Steve
Rogers captain America is being sworn in as
US president that he punches him into a reality
where it seems like wakandans took over the entire planet
Like this is a version of New York City if
Wakanda had expanded its borders then he punches
into a reality where it seems like earth never
left the dark ages, or you could theorize
that Ultron also punched him back in time
and into an alternate universe at the same
time he punches into an earth with the scrolls
took over the planet.
Then he punches them back to the Ice Age reality
version of earth in the watcher barely manages to escape
While Ultron returns to the watchers extradimensional
base just using it as a nexus to the entire
multiverse vowing to bring peace his peace
to the entire multiverse.
If you kind of confused about how this connects
with the timeline of the what if episode 7 ending scene
Like the watcher seem like he was learning
about Ultron for the first time when he stepped
out into party Thor's universe.
But in this episode, it seem like he learns
about Ultron for the first time in this universe
that doesn't really make sense because if
party Thor's universe is the first universe
that Ultron went to next then why would the
watcher be surprised like this and if he was
watching party Thor from his place inside
this base year were Ultron is at the end of
the episode than the timeline between episode
seven episode 8 is just a little bit wonky
so I think they just messed up the timeline
of the scenes a little bit.
They said they had to delay the iron man's
Sakaar episode till next season, so that might
be why there's a timeline issue between episode
seven episode 8.
But that we kind of get a post credit scene
I don't of I call it a traditional post credit scene
But the watcher slinks his way back to dark
Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange supreme to
recruit him and get his help assembling the
multiverse avengers team that they're calling
the guardians of the multiverse.
So what if episode nine the finale next week
will basically be them putting the team together
quickly in and stopping Ultron using that
Zola AI they have confirm what if season to
the be 9 episodes and they said the gonna
try and release it next year.
So we'll talk a little bit about that after
I do my what if finale video next week.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs in the
episode that I didn't talk about in the video
just right them blown the comments my full
venom let there be carnage post credit scene
will post tomorrow night because the movie
is out pretty much everywhere in my full Easter
eggs and break down for the movie will play
post on Friday.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my new Spider-Man No way Home Trailer
video for all the Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield, Easter eggs and click here for my
new a turtles trailer video for the celestials.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next one!